reason was free the nipple a big thing
here there was more in New York like a
lot of gals were they decided they were
gonna protest that men could be topless
but they can't be a hopless and they
passed that right I I had a friend that
she was telling me and we had this
conversation and she was like no but
like a female female breasts aren't
sexual so I should be allowed to show
him and I was like look you know that I
know that my penis doesn't know that I'm
sorry if I see tits my dick is gonna get
hard I'm sorry it's not like I respect
you but if if you [ __ ] pull your tits
out my dick is gonna get hard yes we all
work we do we do forget we were animals
but you know it's also that we're just
not used to seeing tits yeah if tits
were out all the time they would
eventually get used to it the problem is
changing gears [ __ ] deaf weird tits
West Coast yeah I don't know man I I
think they should be able to do it
though they want to walk around topless
but the problem is there's too many
[ __ ] you're running into a river of
[ __ ] you're gonna try it go
upstream through that with your tits
hanging out
that's [ __ ] true go to a bar if you
want to go to a bar topless like look
that is chaos yeah yeah that's gonna the
rails yeah you definitely should be able
to do it but I don't think you should
yeah if you are my friend like I say if
in an ideal world she should be able to
yes yeah you should definitely be able
to but do I think you should do it no no
don't do that
people gonna try to suck them the
interim it's like it's if someone's
gonna touch your tits it's it's so rare
you have to be in like the perfect bar
in Asheville North Carolina
you could be there from 10:00 to 2:00
and nobody will touch your tits like one
place someone's gonna touch your tits
people are gross like even even when
girls ariana grande sang at Aretha
Franklin's funeral even that preacher
tried to touch her to him yeah he was
gonna grip yeah so imagine if she had
freed the nipple [ __ ] crazy I would
have gotten here too got her pregnant
yes
but there's there's no argument and
saying they shouldn't do that like right
it shouldn't be a law yeah this is
almost like I mean you can make
parallels to compelled speech because I
don't think that you should be naked and
just walk down the street if you're a
girl you should but you should be
allowed you don't think you should if
you're my friend because I would say
listen you're gonna get harassed it's
it's is way more likely that you'll get
raped yeah I would think I mean I'd like
to know what the I don't want to do a
study that I would like to know what the
statistic I mean I would not like just
please make these people get raped like
just walk around triremes yeah you know
I don't want to do that study but I
think if you live in a tribe like that
uncontacted tribe outside of India they
probably super accustomed to seeing
people naked and it's they probably act
normal it's probably not that big a deal
we're weird you know it's like what's in
the box man what's in the box and we
would cover everything up but that size
are all covered up or feet are covered
up